[Musique]
oh
bien le bonjour chez vous aujourd'hui
nous sommes sur les bords de la volga
dans la ville de saratov centres
culturels économiques et universitaires
dans la région de la volga
fondée à la fin du xvième siècle comme
forteresse sur les frontières sud est ce
de la russie la ville s'est
particulièrement développée au cours du
19ème siècle à cette époque la volga est
devenue la principale voie de transport
du pays faisant de saratov un port
important la population de la ville a
augmenté de manière considérable et
saratov est devenue la ville la plus
importante de la région de la volga au
début du 20e siècle à partir de la
période soviétique elle est aussi
devenue un grand centre industriel
aujourd'hui saratov compte un peu moins
d'un million d'habitants
c'est ici qu'a été inventé au xixème
siècle un instrument de musique étonnant
l'accordéon de saratov se distinguant
par sa tonalité puissante et ses accords
mais le dieu il a conquis le pays mais
ce n'est pas seulement la musique qui
animent la vie culturelle de la ville
l'un des endroits les plus connus de
saratov et le cirque des frères nikitine
à l'époque c'était le deuxième cirque
permanent d'europe il avait été créé en
1876 par les célèbres frères nikitine
artistes de cirque le bâtiment original
n'a pas été conservé la construction du
cirque actuel date du 20e siècle cette
année il a rouvert après d'importants
travaux de restauration qui se sont
étalés sur plusieurs années
pour beaucoup le cirque c'est les rires
et la joie de nos souvenirs d'enfance et
pour notre invité d'aujourd'hui le
cirque c'est toute sa vie il s'appelle
ivan des forges il est docteur il va
nous raconter tout ce que vous avez
toujours voulu savoir sur le cirque sans
jamais avoir osé le demander alors faire
sa connaissance
bonjour yvan bonjour je suis très
content d'être ici le cirque c'est
incroyable bah oui est ce que tu peux me
dire comment tu es arrivé ici j'ai venu
ici avec la compagnie italienne
d'ariston ni naji dresseurs d'animaux et
tu es là pour combien de temps va ici
pour les fêtes de noël c'est à dire à
peu près deux mois et demi après le
syria vrai on repart pour une autre
ville comment se passe ta journée on se
réveille à 8 heures du matin et puis on
commence à soigner nos animaux quoi et
après vers 10 heures nous avons nos
répétitions d'accord que la piste est
libre le matin pour nous pour pouvoir
répéter et l'après midi c'est les autres
artistes qui répètent leur numéro c'est
tous les jours
ouah je fais un jour oui un jour non
parce que je ne veux pas non plus fort
se mettre les animaux toujours dans la
piste sale et comment dire ça les embête
un petit peu à leurs branches de voir
comme le temps est beau on les met
dehors dans le parc ils profitent du
soleil du beau temps il profite du froid
aussi en russie non ce doit être le
froid bien sûr s'il fait du moins dix on
les met pas dehors mais bon les chameaux
et puis disons qu'on a fait un vison en
plus est avec un bisou vision il peut
rester à -10 dehors il ya aucun problème
tient un bon manteau
[Musique]
alors raconte moi on est dans c'est quoi
ces les écuries voilà assez les écuries
du grand cirque de saratov et là je te
présente et où des animaux quoi ah oui
je veux bien combien d'animaux
différents ici on est venu avec des
éléphants on est venu avec des tigres
des serpents des chevaux des autruches
kangourou alors que le bison la ccin oui
c'est le bison sa seat hausse à tous
mais en attendant offrir un petit porte
ici la
taille est pas alors fallu nettoyer et à
vue il aime bien se frotter dans la
paille dans le foin une fois je mets de
la sur un an +2 surpasse corps pour
enlever la sueur à la la la la voiture
où l'apport qu'il connaît
aucun problème là dessus heureusement
parce que sinon je pourrais pas
travailler avec tu lui parles dans
quelle langue en peluche ou parlant
français là oui mais pour les animaux
pour le dressage on parle du français de
l'anglais et de l'allemand pourquoi
est-ce que ça doit être d ordre cours
oui voilà il ya des offres qui
comprendra par exemple en français on
lui dit à genoux
images nous en anglais on peut déjà y y
on n'y pas bien ici c'est trop long oui
c'est court ils aiment ça ils ont
répondu là on dirait non à oui oui il
était ce qu'il veut mais pourquoi tu
nous appelles la couteau tout et
c'est difficile de dresser un bison des
chameaux jours bah tout ça si tu me
disais 30 ans en arrière je te dirai oui
c'est je sais pas par où commencer mais
l'expérience m'a fait que maintenant je
sais à peu près un peu le caractère de
tous les animaux et je sais par où
commencer c'est comme les enfants
allaient à l'école il ya une base ne va
pas mettre un enfant tout de suite à
prendre de l'algèbre 1 alors quand il ya
une base quoi et avec les chameaux là je
vois qu'ils essaient de nous de nous
dire quelque chose ils ont faim on
dirait un corner tu vois ce qu'ils
veulent te regarderai ce jeu je
m'intéresse je vais te montrer ce qu'ils
veulent ils veulent une caresse apa
voilà
tu veux faire un carnet avec moi aussi
ouais ouais ouais ouais je te répète non
mais bon normalement les chameaux sa
mort ça ça craque des fois de temps en
temps c'est monsieur ces amours là
et ça et les chameaux donc aucune aucun
aucune difficulté pour le challenge est
plus intelligente que le dromadaire
d'accord pourquoi parce que ça a plus de
bosses
c'est un peu plus intelligent par
exemple kazan qui est de russie ouais
justin tu croiras pas un tel zèle il
s'appelle kazan oui parce que on
l'achetait à kazan la ville de gaza
d'accord alors il est arrivé à taza on a
donné le nom de kazan ou à un accord et
kazan il est arrivé en quinze jours est
devenu un artiste war tu sais où ils
allaient kazan non à l'abattoir
et donc te tue la récupérer il avait
simon l'a sauvée et il avec l âge il
avait deux ans
[Musique]
une piste la piste et fait spécialement
pour les chevaux pour les animaux
d'accord a fait 13 mètres 50 donc les
chameaux les aime tous à eux c'est leur
tour ils le savent c'est leur endroit
oui ça qu'ici on fait les répétitions on
joue temps en temps on fait un peu de
tout ici on fait pas que du travail
parce que je n'aime pas peur voire aux
animaux que la piste c'est pour le
travail non ok rentrer ici qu'ils soient
contents
et à de tous ceux qui prennent du
plaisir c'est ça voilà exactement étape
à la tête qui tourne là parce que moi je
tourne avec toi et j'ai maintenant et tu
les fais pas tourner de l'autre côté un
moment temps en temps les fait tourner
de l'autre côté oui mais on peut essayer
changez
pas de ce côté là
la fario
voilà enfin le côté ont changé ou encore
la dame ta place brave tous les
dresseurs utilisent ces mêmes ces mêmes
termes veut dire que là si moi je pense
à jeudi le même mot que toi ils vont
écouter peut-être pas bas et vont se
faire comme ça la première fois ils vont
écouter mais la deuxième fois ils vont
dire moi qui suis là
d'où il s'impose comment il avait
adressées et puis après une autre chose
y'a pas que là il ya la voix qui est
importante mais aussi la position
imposition bon là on nous avons cinq
animaux mais bon compte à plusieurs
beaucoup plus d'animaux et la position
est très importante et les chambrière
aussi brillant
ferveur et bouté dans le coeur quand ces
éléments sont réunis aux voix ce
résultat exceptionnel ce qui distingue
ivan des autres dresseurs c'est que vous
ne verrez jamais d'opposition avec
l'animal quand ivan entre dans le manège
vous ne verrez que de l'amour mutuel les
animaux aiment l'homme l'homme aime les
animaux ça c'est justement y va de sa
bonté de coeur
et ils adorent manger mes chaussures
déjà battu
[Musique]
rafa ça suffit kazan down
en train de me tester
[Musique]
depuis quelques années ils vont
travaille pour la compagnie italienne la
dynastie tony key ligne de plus
anciennes familles de l'histoire du
cirque fondée à milan en 1872 leur
cirque est proclamée cirque national par
le roi d'italie aujourd'hui les frères
daviau et corrado représente la sixième
génération et nous avons la chance de
parler avec daviau est ce que tu es le
premier delà de la dynastie à avoir
décidé de venir vivre en russie
travailler en russie
oui on est venu ici à rossi et on peut
découvrir les
la culture russe de l'iss ir pasquet
dans tout le monde entier la culture
russe des cirques c'est quelque chose de
spécial les routes sont très connus pour
les cils que pelé beau spectacle pour
les grandes artistes qui sont amenées
pour tout le monde entier
sa spécialité c'est les tigres oui tu
leur parles en quelle langue avec
l'amour je parle avec un support avec
amour tu leur transmet les ombres et
amoureuse et ils comprennent c'est ça
c'est ça
moi je vous aime
là bas
[Musique]
nous on donne beaucoup mieux et dont
beaucoup même si tonton coistia vraiment
d'amour c'est pas en question des
saumons de travail c'est une manière
spécifique à l'italienne avant il y
avait des dresseurs puis des dompteurs
et maintenant il ya un nouveau courant
d'éducateurs quand l'interaction avec
l'animal n'est pas seulement tourné vers
la récompense sous forme de nourriture
vais quand elle se fait les yeux dans
les yeux et avec l'intonation c'est dans
cette direction que va le cirque donc
toi tu dresses les tigres puis adresser
tous les animaux possibles et
imaginables
aujourd'hui tu travailles avec avec yvan
et ça va être 7,84 oui c'est un bon
train sur le rsa oui oui ça va maría il
ya quelqu'un qui la latitude de murs
pour desceller l'effort
quelqu'un qui est mieux pour dresser les
chevaux et choses comme ça il y en a
t-il tout très bien sans famille il
faisait les chevaux il en connaît très
bien les chevaux et très bien
comment ces présents et un an on ne peut
pas s'asseoir le dos à la piste hawkman
c'est vrai oui mais tu me fais peur
tu as commencé depuis tout jeune dans le
dans le cirque c'est ça je suis né large
cirque tu te voyais de toute façon toute
ta vie dans le cirque
toute la vie c'est ça j'avais 18 ans
j'avais envie d'être
pompiers et oui tu as tout de suite
saisi que tu savais parler aux animaux
c'est le dieu baisse aurait été tué et
moi je toute ma vie j'étais avec les
animaux puis je me suis dit un jour
pourquoi pas commencer à les dresser
quand tu es bon dans quelque chose je
pense qu'il faut suivre toujours cette
route
[Musique]
yvan d'efforts je né en 1970 dans
l'essonne son père travaille alors dans
un centre hippique et sa mère dans une
banque peu de temps après le père d'yves
ans quitte son emploi et montrent une
troupe de voltige cosaque tout en
suivant ses parents qui se produisent
dans des cirques il parc d'attractions
yvan fait ses études par correspondance
dès l'âge de 9 ans il commence lui même
la voltige sur un poney dans un parc
d'attractions sur le thème de la
conquête de l'ouest la famille voyage
ensuite en espagne dans les îles
canaries puis au portugal
après plusieurs années yvan qu'il ses
parents pour mener sa propre carrière et
se spécialise dans le dressage des
animaux il reste une quinzaine d'années
au portugal dans un cirque puis mène une
carrière itinérante dans de nombreux
pays d'europe en 2016 il rencontre
lettonie
célèbre famille du cirque italien où il
est invité à monter un numéro d'animaux
exotiques dans le cirque d'arx tony
sylva ans commence alors avec eux des
tournées en europe de l'est en ukraine
il participe à un festival du cirque à
odessa où il remporte le prix du
meilleur artiste et le second prix pour
son numéro d'animaux exotiques avec
l'ethnie yvan arrive en 2018 en russie
où il effectue des tournées à travers
tout le pays désormais il va en vie en
russie avec son épouse bien la russe
maria avec qui il a eu un fils prénommé
david
alors ivan est ce que tu peux nous
présenter un petit peu ta ta petite
famille l'a bien sûr je vous présente ma
chat de forges
david tu parle français bonjour tu sais
pas encore parce que il a deux ans oui
bon il est un peu perdue parce que il
entendu français ont entendu russe et
ils entendent de l'anglais parce que moi
avec ma femme je peux me communiquera
les en anglais et puis bon avec mon fils
je parle tout en français quoi tu parles
pas un petit peu russe tu comprends
leurs heures ni peux me dise mans un
très doucement
et où est ce qu'on a ici qu'est ce
qu'est ce que c'est cet appartement ici
c'est l'appartement crillon fournit le
cirque d'accord et que tu viens tu viens
avec tes valises quoi revoilà avec mes
valises bien aucun meuble qui
t'appartient
david s'il te plaît david voulait parler
tu peux pas rien c'est ça
ben tu nous raconter des histoires bon
ben voila nous avant on partait avec nos
caravanes voitures et camions quoi mais
maintenant c'est fini on pour tout
seulement nos valises quoi on voyage
beaucoup ma femme voyages en train ou en
avion avec mon enfant mais moi je voyage
avec les animaux je contrôle tout les
années de mariage moi tu regrettes pas
un petit peu peut-être là la vie d'avant
la vie de caravanes la vie de bohème un
peu bas
bon des fois monté le cirque démonter
tout ça c'est vrai que ça me manque un
peu ce que vous mangez une personne qui
n'aime pas rester assis sur un fauteuil
toute la journée je suis une personne
qui aime bouger alors bon avant-goût
télé cirque ont démonté on voyageait
c'est vrai que mais bon avec l'âge aussi
on aime bien ça mais on va leur petit
confort voilà exactement c'est vrai que
j'ai plus 20 ans quoi
racontez moi un petit peu la vie de
nomade c'est comment parce que c'est
toujours en train de te balader à une
nomade en europe c'était très très dur
parce que nous changeons de ville tous
les deux trois jours et un nouveau nos
caravanes nos animaux tous à nouveau
voyager c'est difficile mais on est
habitué parce que bon je suis né dans le
cirque et j'ai fait ça toute ma vie et
ça n'était pas trop difficile pour toi
de deux de faire cette vie de nomade
c'est difficile il faut être né dans le
monde du cirque et vivre dans le cirque
dans une famille de cirque pour que ce
soit facile parce que pour moi c'est une
vie dans les valises tout le temps quand
on change de valises une valise pour
l'hiver une valise pour l'été toi aussi
tu as comme raconté un match à deux
valises une valise divers il réalise des
débats oui comme ça oui oui et oui et
puis après on a la vaisselle tout ça
parce qu'il faut bien manger aussi
oui et tout ça pour le transporter
tu te vois
continuer à vivre en russie longtemps
bah moi je vous dis une chose moi je
suis bien où je suis et aucun problème
ce qui m'a beaucoup plu ici en russie
c'est que les gens adorent le cirque oui
et puis quand vous travaillez dans la
piste de cirque vous avez des
applaudissements incroyable oui c'est
une chose qui vous vient au coeur
imaginez vous ici en russie c'est toute
l'année qui travaillent iris par exemple
un spectacle d'un mois et demi ils
ferment deux semaines pour répéter le
nouveau spectacle et ça repart c'est
comme ça tout le temps alors ça veut
dire que les gens aiment le cirque
[Musique]
alors on est dans ta logiciels comme ça
aujourd'hui tu mets quelques costumes tu
sais déjà au lequel tu veux lequel je
veux avec utilisant la sympathique ada
costume de toréador non celui-là il a
l'air
celui là bas qu elle adore
[Musique]
les animaux réagissent à par rapport à
tes costumes par rapport à tes ges par
rapport à quoi les points où ils ont
peur des costumes s'ils sont différents
et costumes dans une fois j'ai travaillé
en arabe est un costume tout blanc les
animaux avaient très très peur alors bon
parce que ce qu'on a fait on en a fait
des répétitions tranquille avec le
costume puis bon et j'y suis habitué et
puis voilà est ce que tes animaux porte
des costumes aussi j'ai bien compris ce
qui est des biens sur ces des costumes
qui n'aime pas ceux qui ne supportent
pas ben c'est vrai que aussi pour par
exemple pour les chameaux on a fait des
costumes avec des franges et puis
j'avais un chameau qui arrêtait pas de
sauter parce que les proches de toucher
les jambes mais tout ça c'est une bonne
chose parce qu'on on les apprend un peu
on les répète et puis voilà c'est comme
le costume ils doivent s'habituer quoi
menacer le maison tu mets un costume
sans enjeu mais pas de costumes parce
qu'on perd du temps là il va tout casser
ça sert à rien quand vous non plus
toujours lui non parce que je n'ai pas
dit je n'aime pas habiller les animaux
de trop parce que c'est comme si on les
prenait pour des clowns et j'aime pas ça
j'aime bien naturel avant le spectacle
est-ce que tu as je sais pas une
tradition à ce qu'il ya des préparations
à faire comment tu prépares les animaux
et si j'ai un travail énorme un bon les
numéros dure à peu près tous les animaux
ensemble dure à peu près 20 minutes mais
je passe à peu près plus d'une heure à
préparer avec l'employé tous les animaux
à les nettoyer à l'état pour qu'il soit
propre pour le spectacle est
géré le spectacle commence je crois que
c'est toi et qui rentrent le premier
avec le cheval oui avec le cheval et
qu'est ce qu'on ressent ces moments là
moi je vais te dire tout de suite assez
bon moi je suis en train de promener mon
cheval pour le chauffer quoi avant de
rentrer bien des fois j'ai vraiment pas
envie tu sais c'est jusqu'où les jours
tu as envie de travailler depuis deux
jours n'a pas trop envie alors bon tu
vas être cheval mais quand tu rentres en
piste tu vois ce public qui fait vivre à
tous leur donnes tout ce que tu as dans
le coeur et tu essaies de toujours de
faire le mieux possible pour
[Musique]
travaillé dans un cirque c'est une
vocation c'est un art de vivre c'est un
métier qu'est ce que les animaux t-on
appris je veux dire une chose comment
après je préfère les animaux que les
humains des fois qu'est ce qu'on peut
trouver au cirque qu'on ne trouve pas
ailleurs
on veut dire que ce qu'on ne trouve pas
ailleurs à ce que nous on est toujours
en train de voyager on voit des villes
toutes les semaines ou tous les mois des
endroits magnifiques et que beaucoup de
gens ne peuvent pas voir qu'est ce qui
te manque en russie rien parce que j'ai
ma famille ici en russie avec moi et je
suis très content et quel animal n'as tu
pas encore dompté que je n'ai pas dans
le tempo et
ma femme
je n'arrive pas d'adressé
je te remercie on a passé un excellent
moment je te souhaite encore beaucoup de
spectacle peut-être espérer d'eux tu
arrives à dompter ta femme qui
merci en tout cas pourtant hockey à dire
merci
on va voir
et voilà notre émission touche à sa fin
nous l'avons pas fait avec un amoureux
des animaux y vend des forges nous a
montré tout son art dans leur dressage
de nouveaux lieux de nouvelles
personnalités tout aussi intéressant
vous attendre il ya très bientôt sur
arte france
[Musique]